[Musique]
le pôle biologique pharmashimi de son
petit nom BPC qu'on l'appelle c'est le
dernier établissement universitaire à
s'implanté sur sur le quartier de Moulon
qui regroupe l'ancienne Faculté de
pharmacie qui était implantée à
Châtenay-Malabry l'Institut de chimie
moléculaire et de matériaux qui est
implanté effectivement sur l'université
Orsay puis un stand de master biologie
et chimie ça regroupe 3300 étudiants
1000 enseignants chercheurs et
administratifs donc ça fait quand même
un bâtiment qui regroupe plus de 4000
usagers
[Musique]
donc ici on se trouve devant le cœur de
pôle ce qu'on a appelé le coeur de Paul
ça veut dire que toutes les fonctions
publiques de l'université donc c'est un
projet qui a fait l'objet d'un programme
très très précis
puisqu'on regroupe ici à peu près 100000
mètres carrés de plateau d'enseignements
mais surtout une recherche sur la
synergie entre l'enseignement magistral
de la biologie la chimie et la pharmacie
mais avec la recherche aussi donc on a
un très grand bâtiment qui fait à peu
près 30 000 m² à lui seul et qui lui
regroupe donc les plateaux de
laboratoire dans lequel s'effectuera la
recherche de l'Université Paris-Saclay
le projet doit être conçu plutôt comme
une mini ville c'est-à-dire qu'on a
vraiment cherché à disséminer sur ce
site
à peu près 6 bâtiments qui sont reliés
entre eux par des passerelles en verre
et qui permet justement cette liaison
complète avec les autres parties des
bâtiments
cette projet dit BPC pour biologie
chimie pharmacie aussi un second pied
qui est l'idée
est un institut plutôt axé sur la
recherche qui a permis de regrouper
trois gros laboratoires agissants autour
de l'évolution du développement et des
écosystèmes
le fait de rassembler dans des locaux
neufs extrêmement fonctionnels avec une
qualité d'équipement scientifique de
très haut niveau permet de faciliter
le regroupement la synergie entre un
certain nombre d'actions de recherche
pour l'intérêt général et celui de
l'université Paris-Saclay au sens large